just like any profession the movie
industry is filled with a wide variety
of personalities that sometimes clash
with one another especially when some of
those personalities belong to
notoriously difficult performers or
otherwise decent actors who get carried
away during the grueling process of
making big-budget movies and television
earning them does not play well with
others reputation actors like William
Shatner over the years several of
William Shatner's former cast mates have
commented on the Star Trek stars
allegedly difficult attitude he's
reportedly upset plenty of co-stars and
even caused some feuds along the way
Shatner and fellow Trek that Leonard
Nimoy clashed over scripts and fan mail
and Shatner is said to be excessively
sensitive to stories that favored Nimoy
later in life the pair patched up the
differences but that belated
reconciliation may be a rare exception
for Chapman reportedly Shatner and
Nichelle Nichols with whom he shared TVs
first interracial kiss did not get along
well at all and she nearly left the show
until dr. Martin Luther King convinced
Nichols of the importance of her role
Shatner later made waves when he refused
to appear on stage with James Doohan at
a convention in 2004 doin's farewell
appearance following his Alzheimer's
diagnosis there's also the long-running
feud between George Takei and Shatner
who've been at odds often publicly for
several decades there's such a sickness
there it's so painfully obvious that
there is a psychosis well I think his
stability is quite questionable
the shannen doherty although she's
managed to put her public feuds with
cast mates behind her since her 2015
cancer diagnosis shannen doherty
reportedly was notoriously hard to get
along with on the sets of both Beverly
Hills 90210 and charmed
during her 9:02 1o years Geordi clashed
with her co-stars including toys
spelling who recounted an incident when
Dougherty and Ginny Garth nearly got
into a fistfight Spelling has admitted
that she ultimately asked her father
nine oh two one oh producer Aaron
Spelling too fired early years after the
show ended Jason Priestley wrote
candidly about dirties attitude in his
memoir and Doherty responded by saying
he had brain damage from a car accident
on the set of charmed Geordi ran into
problems again this time with co-star
Alyssa Milano who described the
situation as very much sort of like high
school Dougherty agreed there's too much
drama on the set and not enough passion
for the work whatever caused the issues
they proved to be too much for Dougherty
or producer Aaron Spelling to handle and
she left the series after the third
season Wesley Snipes despite being a
household name Wesley Snipes has
developed a bad reputation in Hollywood
for his onset antics most notoriously
during the production of 2004 is blade
Trinity according to co-star Patton
Oswalt Snipes insisted on being called
blade and would rarely leave his trailer
he'd walk by his trailer and this wall
of of pot stench would just like whoa
and look kind of push you to the side
Oswalt also recounted a much more
serious incident in which Snipes tried
to strangle the director David Goyer
after which lawyer proposed that Snipes
quit and his stand-in finished the film
this allegedly freaked Snipes out so
much that he stopped talking to Goyer
altogether after a while he resorted to
just give he will communicate with with
post-its that he would give to the
director and each one he would sign
blade after filming for blade Trinity
ended Snipes sued Goyer and New Line
Cinema claiming they withheld part of
his salary and didn't allow him to be
part of the creative process
he was also allegedly upset because some
of his screen time had been reduced in
favor of Jessica Biel and Ryan
the suit was later settled out of court
Lindsay Lowen after racking up a string
of early hits as a Disney starlet
Lindsay Lowen set about compiling a
record of partying hard and leaving
frustrated directors and co-stars in her
wake on the set of 2007 s Georgia rule
Lowen caused so many problems with her
tardiness and no-shows reportedly
costing the production half a million
dollars a day that producer James
Robinson's enter an ultimatum saying
quote I'm not going to put up with it
in 2012 a source from the set of Glee
complained that the actress had been a
total nightmare again showing up several
hours late to shoot it seems that
tardiness is a bad habit of loewen's a
year later anger management coasts our
Charlie Sheen told Jay Leno that Loen
had been late to the set by several
hours and had later borrowed a couple of
bracelets from the production which the
show later deducted from her paycheck
the same year New York Times magazine
published here is what happens when
you've cast Lindsay Lohan in your movie
a piece chronicling some of loewen's
most unbelievable misadventures on the
set appalled Schrader's that canyons
among her offenses not showing up to set
big surprise Edward Norton though he's
apparently become more easygoing in
recent years it's been a hard battle to
repair the damage at Norton caused to
his reputation in the past that
reputation a supposedly impossible
perfectionist whose siphons creative
control for himself while Norton is
infamous for insisting the producers
give him say over the final cut of the
1998 drama American history acts he
surged back into the headlines while
promoting 2008's The Incredible Hulk the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is generally
action-packed explosive and witty but
when Edward Norton signed on to play
Bruce Banner he wanted a longer more
nuanced film with a deeper dive into
banners backstory Universal put its foot
down and the creative differences
spiraled out of control
Norton barely even promoted the film and
took off for a humanitarian trip to
Africa after the premiere arguably
harming the flicks box office bottom
line so in other words you wouldn't like
Norton when he's angry
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you